non c'est l'anecdote moi je sais pas je
vois quand tu es vraiment comme je les
ai vécus
c'est un peu ma les ans je vais tous et
laissez-moi tousser et je vous raconte
ça c'est l'histoire dans les autres
rencontres des moments les plus mal
raison de mon existence mais je pense à
peu fait rigoler des gens c'est aussi
regarder je me blesse
alors c'est les cette histoire en fait
j'étais dans un café où j'allais tout le
temps dans ce café j allais notamment
parce qu'il y avait une fille j'avais
craqué sur elle l'était absolument
magnifique voilà et et je m'étais dit à
force de revenir dans ce café à un
moment donné la discussion entre elle et
moi va arriver naturellement c'était ça
ma stratégie je me suis pas dit je vais
aller la voir et salut comment tu vas je
voulais qu un jour naturellement on se
parle et que l ai pas l'impression que
en fait moi dans ma tête j'ai tout
organisé depuis très longtemps ok et un
jour cette discussion arrive donc moi je
suis comme un dingue elle arrive
naturellement je te jure elle est
magnifique on est tous les deux là genre
on est tous les deux la file du café
naturellement comme si comme si je
n'avais jamais voulu parler de ma vie a
l'impression que je suis tombé dans sa
vie de nulle part là on se retrouve à
s'asseoir à la même table et on discute
hockey et il y avait un autre mec hockey
qui était toujours dans le café et je
pense qu'il a vu mon jeu lui il savait
très bien à quoi je jouais et ils nous
regardent il est dégoûté tête il était
aussi amoureux de la fille je sais pas
mais il est dégoûté ayez en espèces de
triangle qui se joue ou moi je parle
avec cette fille je suis super content
je me c'est le moment de ta vie et il ya
ce gars ou lui il m'a cramé vraiment il
m'a cramé il me regarde en mode espèces
d'escrocs vas tu es tu vas voir ya une
rivalité et là je me retrouve dans cette
situation extrêmement malaise entre où
j'ai extrêmement envie de chier les amis
je peux pas le dire autrement je peux
pas vous le dire autrement j'ai une
envie j'ai mal au ventre et j'ai pas le
choix et je me dis c'est mon
opportunités là je peux pas j'ai pas le
choix il faut que je gère cette
situation je vais aux toilettes et j'y
vais et les toilettes comment elles sont
faites c'est un espèce de longs couloirs
donc c'est à une porte et c'est un long
couloir est à l'étoile est au fond donc
une fois que tu as ouvert la porte à
jour si pas pour arriver aux toilettes
tu vois et j'arrive je m'installe sur
les toilettes et là je suis sur les
toilettes et je réalise que j'ai pas mis
le look et j'ai pas fermé la porte et
j'entendais pas qui arrivent mais moi je
suis sur les toilettes là j'ai deux
options
je me dis soit je me lève je cours et je
peux risquer de pas arrivés à temps et
qu'il ouvre la porte et que je suis
comme ça devant tout le café parce qu'il
faut dire aussi que la porte et donne
surtout café un soin j'assume et je me
pose sur les toilettes et je l'attends
en mode oui qu'est ce qui se passe je
suis bien je suis là je choisis la très
mauvaise option
de me lever j'ai le pantalon aux
chevilles donc en fait on passe pas de
sipa on est à 12 pas et j'avance comme
çà et là la porte s'ouvre et j'arrive à
rattraper la poignée comme s'attaque et
donc je suis là te bats l'air en tenir
la porte avec un eye contact de la
personne et c'est le mec c'est l'autre
mec et il me regarde désormais comme ça
et on a un contact de fou comme ça et là
et et ce moment là j'ai voilà c'est un
des moments les plus intenses de ma vie
parce que lui il est en train d'essayer
d'ouvrir la porte et moi je suis en
train de la retenir et l'a donc après je
m'en vais cheminée je me dis mais
comment je vais ressortir de sainte foy
et yahia et j'avais cette opportunité du
café américain
avait là bas et finalement j'ai fait
l'air de rien comme si tout était sympa
mais quel moment extraordinaire ce
liquide à quel moment de solitude ce
moment où je tiens la porte comme cela
et lui tire la porte et je suis à poil
devant tout le café 1 quel moment
extraordinaire c'est comme dans les
films effectivement et c'est votre
authenticité aussi c'est bien là qu'on
la voit votre vérité